The Marvel Cinematic Universe is getting a
little smaller, as thousands of theaters around
the world decline to screen its recent movies.
Here's why countries around the world are
apparently banning the series' new movies,
and what it might mean for the future of the
MCU.
"Thor: Love and Thunder" is finally here,
and the film's early box office numbers indicate
that it's going to be another financial success
story for Marvel and Disney.
According to The Numbers, Taika Waititi's
follow-up to "Thor: Ragnarok" gave the god
of thunder's solo franchise its biggest opening
to date, having made over $300 million after
its first weekend in theaters.
That's a lot of dough for the space Viking.
This is despite the fact that "Thor: Love
and Thunder" has divided critics and fans
alike.
While some people enjoy the humorous take
on the Thor mythos, others feel like the movie
is too jokey for its own good.
However, mixed reviews could be the least
of the film's concerns as it continues to
roll out in theaters worldwide.
While "Thor: Love and Thunder" is shaping
up to be an international super hit, the movie
looks set to be banned in certain regions
that have been profitable for Hollywood blockbusters
in recent years.
If the movie does indeed face the chopping
block in these regions, it will mark yet another
Disney release to be banned for the same reason
in 2022.
"Let's bring the rainbow."
"'Bring the rainbow,' is that her catchphrase
or something?"
"Thor: Love and Thunder" is the latest Disney
release to feature brief moments of LGBTQ
representation, which could prevent the movie
from being granted a release in China and
other territories.
The latest Marvel release implies that Valkyrie
is bisexual, with her mentioning she had a
girlfriend back in the day.
It also reveals that Korg is effectively gay,
being a part of a species that only has one
gender.
Industry experts believe that these aspects
will be enough to stop the movie from being
released in certain regions.
Taika Waititi and Natalie Portman have also
been celebrating the LGBTQ aspects of "Thor:
Love and Thunder," with the pair having recently
described the movie as, quote, "so gay," and
quote, "super gay," at a Q&A and screening.
However, they were subsequently criticized
by Marvel fans as scenes involving positive
LGBTQ representation in the movie are actually
few and far between, which is unfortunate
considering the film is reported to have originally
included a significant romantic scene involving
Valkyrie that was cut, presumably to appease
censors.
It's an unfortunate happenstance, especially
seeing as how Valkyrie was supposed to have
her sexuality play a more prominent role in
"Thor: Ragnarok," but that ended up getting
cut, as well.
If the situation follows the same trajectory
as "Lightyear," which includes a same-gender
kissing scene, "Thor: Love and Thunder" could
also be banned in territories such as the
Middle East, Malaysia, and Indonesia.
Reportedly, the Disney-Pixar release is currently
banned in 14 countries.
"Flick!"
"Okay, we should go."
"Thor: Love and Thunder" isn't the first Marvel
film to have an issue getting released in
other countries, and if current trajectories
are any indication, it certainly won't be
the last.
Phase 4 of the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
been faced with bans around the globe, particularly
when it came to the release of "Eternals."
That film faced bans in Kuwait, Qatar, and
Saudi Arabia due to the inclusion of a same-sex
relationship.
In that movie, Phastos is married to a man
named Ben, and the two share a kiss.
Homosexuality is banned through much of the
region, and movies depicting LGBTQ relationships
tend to get banned.
That was the case with the most recent Marvel
flick before "Thor 4" — "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness."
That film was banned in the same countries,
seemingly due to America Chavez' parents being
in a lesbian relationship.
Additionally, those movies, as well as "Shang-Chi
and the Legend of the Ten Rings" were banned
in China for various reasons.
It remains to be seen if the next movie in
the MCU, "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever,"
will make its way to China's shores, but things
aren't looking hopeful.
Despite that, these movies seem to still be
making plenty of money no matter what.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.